les masques on en parle avec samuel
françois professeur de droit privé à
l'université de rennes et bruno m'égare
ban chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière de paris
bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france après les
yvelines a préparé la loire atlantique
juste pas à son tour l'obligation de
porter le masque à l'extérieur samuel
françois la boîte de pandore est ouverte
il était probable aurel
la décision du tribunal
aduriz prudence comme on dit si les
jurés car sa motivation les répliques à
blanc réalité à toutes les hypothèses
dans lesquelles le préfet aurait prime
il a été trop généraux d'obligations a
dû reporter
ses décisions puissent se multiplier oui
d'ailleurs on commence à parler de cette
décision du côté des thés des
hauts-de-seine peut-être prochainement
bruno meyer ban comment est-ce que vous
accueillez ses suspensions d'arrêtés
préfectoraux en cascade
écoutez en termes épi épidémiologique
nous n'avons jamais pensé que le port du
masque en espaces ouverts à l'extérieur
pouvaient contribuer de façon
significative à réduire les
contaminations il faut savoir qu'avec
lakovic 19 la propagation se fait
essentiellement par les aérosols c'est à
dire des particules microscopiques que
l'on aimé en parlant en criant en tous
sens et qui flotte dans l'air lorsque
vous parlez en air ambiant à l'extérieur
eh bien ces particules sont
immédiatement dilué car évidemment le
volume est extrêmement vaste et donc le
risque d'être contaminé faible sauf si
vous êtes à une distance très proche et
que on vous projette des postillons
directement sur vos voies respiratoires
donc en dehors de quelques ruelles
extrêmement étroite de marché où on est
statique ou discutent sans bouger
où les serrés les uns contre les autres
dans la rue il n'y a pas de risque de
contamination à linverse évidemment le
port du masque doit rester très
strictement observées dans les espaces
clos public mal aérée bruno m'égare ban
donc on a entendu beaucoup de réactions
de parisiens de franciliens satisfait de
cette suspension donc vous êtes d'accord
m le masque dehors quand il n'y a
personne ça ne sert à rien donc les
français sont capables de faire le
distinguo entre un lieux densément
peuplées un espace qui n'est beaucoup
moins donc le le port du masque à à
toute heure et par tous nés est une
décision disproportionnée
j'aurais tendance à dire oui
effectivement l'objectif initial des
préfets qui ont pris une cette mesure
c'était était probalement d'ordre
psychologique c'est à dire faire
comprendre à la population que nous
sommes dans une période de circulation
extrêmement élevée du virus et qu'il y à
des risques de contamination si on
respecte pas les mesures barrières mais
en pratique évidemment tous les médias
depuis maintenant 15 jours affiche le
nombre de contaminations avait que 6 0
donc on parle par milliers de constater
centaines de millier de contaminations
donc plus personne n'ignore que le coc
vide au micro et partout d'ailleurs plus
personne ne connaît pas de dames et de
deux personnes de parents qu'ils soient
contaminés donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faut faire appel
plutôt à la responsabilisation
désormais on sait tous évidemment qu'il
faut mettre le masque lorsqu'on est à
moins de deux mètres dans un espace clos
d'une autre personne a fortiori si on la
connaît pas parce qu'il existe un risque
de contamination même si cette personne
est totalement asymptomatiques un appel
à la responsabilisation des français
samuel françois les
les décisions gouvernementales de porter
le masque à l'extérieur c'est quoi ces
infantiliser les français la population
en gros c'est peut-être simplifiez vous
mettez le masque dehors donc au moins on
est sûr que vous le mettez ces certains
l'oublient quand ils sont dans des
marchés ou dans des ruelles densément
peuplées
oui il ya plusieurs choses dans ce cas
dit le professeur et dans votre question
la première chose c'est de dire que à ce
jour ce soir il n'y a plus d' arrêter
donc les parisiens risquent rien en
termes d'amande à se promener sans
masques dans la rue mais le préfet la
revoir sa copie et un nouvel arrêté sera
pris avec
à priori des des zonages et des horaires
à respecter donc on à revenir ou pas en
ce moment gabriel atta le porte parole
du gouvernement tout à l'heure un nouvel
arrêté sera prochainement déposée par le
ministère de l'intérieur mais ça veut
dire quoi jusqu'où va aller ce bras de
fer administratif
la déclaration gabriel attentes pour le
pour le pour le savoir peut-être mais là
où d'accord avec le professeur c'est de
dire que peut-être qu'au lieu dans kid
et
ses règlements un appel au bon sens des
français qui vivent maintenant depuis
deux ans avec cette épidémie pourrait
être tentée pourrait être parier et qui
vous n'obtiendrez pital de meilleurs
résultats que avec des règles aussi
général et aussi peu proportionnée ou
alors aussi compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre lorsqu'il s'agit de déracinés ou
d'american megaman un appel au bon sens
vous y croyez
oui je crois qu'effectivement ans
maintenant sauf exception tout le monde
a bien compris que nous avons à faire un
virus est responsable d'une maladie
grave
lorsque launay âgées avec des
comorbidités ou notamment lorsqu'on
n'est pas vaccinée donc de fait
évidemment toutes ces personnes doivent
être extrêmement prudentes car la
circulation du virus est encore
extrêmement élevé d'ailleurs elle est
encore en phase d'expansion et nous
avons toujours
circulation importante du variant delta
avec 30000 contamination jours donc il
faut surtout pas levé la vigilance
aujourd'hui ça serait dommage d'être
contaminés aujourd'hui est de finir en
réanimation en pratique évidemment les
personnes ça suspendre ces arrêtés est
ce que justement c'est faire fi de la
vigilance que c'est pas un peu
irresponsable de lutter contre le port
du masque au bout de la situation
sanitaire
non je ne crois pas parce qu'en fait
c'est cet arrêté deux en face et ses
suspensions d'arrêter ne concerne pas
bien sûr le port du masque et le respect
des mesures barrières stricte dans les
lieux clos public d'ailleurs même il
faudrait c'est là évidemment le trou
dans la raquette
essayé de respecter ces mesures y
compris dans certaines circonstances en
milieu privé avec ses amis avec ses
parents notamment lorsqu on est en
présence de personnes extrêmement
fragile mais je crois que la population
a disparu tel masque avec avec sa femme
son père sa mère à la maison et ses
enfants non j'ai dit que lorsque vous
vous réunissez avec des personnes qui ne
sont pas de votre foyer strict des amis
des des parents comme cela s'est fait
aux fêtes de noël il faut être prudent
notamment lorsque vous avez des
personnes âgées ou immunodéprimées
des personnes non vaccinées oui
effectivement si vous recevez chez vous
une personne non vaccinés je vous
recommande de porter le masque ou de lui
demander de porter le masque car sinon
vous pourriez être à l'origine d'une
contamination de sept personnes et qui
malheureusement la conduisent en
réanimation et vous le regretteriez plus
tard on a beaucoup parlé des masques
ffp2 notamment pour pour l'école
d'ailleurs une information ce soir 14
1380 écoles sont fermées aujourd'hui on
était à
9200 la semaine dernière c'est le plus
haut niveau depuis le printemps 2020 ça
vous évoque quoi vous
samuel françoise ce nouveau chiffre ce
soir
si vous voulez les chiffres qui sont
annoncés tous les jours
deux lettres pris en compte parce qu'ils
sont importants mais en tant que juriste
ici quand je commente cette décision je
la commente avec en bagages les règles
juridiques lé principe de droit et je
crois que ce sont ces principes ces
règles juridiques qui ont été rappelés
par le tribunal administratif de paris
pour qu'il pousse donc les dissiper cela
faisait longtemps que on attendait des
décisions de justice qui viennent
vraiment exercer un contrôle plein sur
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
cette décision est vraiment absolument
remarquable vous avez cité dans votre
reportage les la motivation de l'urgence
par le juge contre lui fin du match les
contraintes physiques et respiratoires
que représente le port du masque
systématique en extérieur les entraves
que cette obligation induit en matière
de communication et de 10 social c'est
ça devait je crois être 17 important
port ce terrain là ce n'est pas un geste
anodin ce n'est pas un geste banal ce
n'est pas un geste auquel on peut
s'habituer donc voilà sur le plan
juridique mois 7,7 décision vraiment me
radier je crois qu'elle est elle redonne
aussi un peu d'espoir
on ne m'égare ban demain six cent mille
français verront leurs passes sanitaire
être invalidés faute de rappel vaccinal
et au sujet du post vaccinales la classe
politique s'écharpant encore aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale si on n'avait
pas supprimé 5700 liés en 2020 à
l'hôpital malgré l'épidémie de kobe dont
on en serait là aujourd'hui parce qu'on
est en train de débattre sur les
guéguerres administrative liée au port
du masque à l'extérieur ou non alors
qu'à la base le problème est plus
profond de votre confrère par exemple du
kremlin bicêtre le professeur jean luc
bohl appelle un plan marshall de
l'hôpital n'a pas de candidat à la
présidentielle
oui vous avez raison effectivement mais
à mon sens ces deux problèmes qui se
surajoutent et se complètent on va dire
d'abord effectivement il faut tout faire
en termes épidémique pour prévenir les
infections et les maladies graves donc
ça c'est important et la vaccination
aujourd'hui est le moyen le plus simple
d'éviter de se retrouver à l'hôpital
avec une forme grave de la maladie voire
d'y laisser sa donc tout ce qui va pour
encourager la vaccination est
parfaitement pertinent scientifiquement
et médicalement à côté de ça évidemment
il faut donner à l'hôpital public les
moyens de travailler et donc depuis
plusieurs années alors ça n'est pas les
quelques suppressions de lits
cette année
[Musique]
tu y avoir de temps en temps d
adaptation du nombre de lits c'est à
dire de transformation de lits peut-être
dans des hôpitaux on va dire moins
utiles à des
pour délits plus spécialisés ou dans des
zones plus on va dire en difficulté donc
tout ça se comprend mais malheureusement
depuis maintenant une vingtaine d'années
la seule boussole des gestionnaires de
l'hôpital public et des autorités
administratives c'est la comptabilité
c'est à dire avoir à la fin de
l'exercice un exercice bénéficiaire et
en comblant les déficits par la
réduction du personnel soignant et par
la réduction du nombre de lits sans
tenir compte des besoins de santé
évidemment de la population qui vieillit
avec
d une médecine qui progresse des
thérapeutiques de plus en plus coûteuses
et puis surtout un personnel qui ne
retrouve plus son compte dans cet
hôpital où la mission de soi a disparu
ou ont fait face essentiellement à des
tâches administratives
des actes qu'il faut faire pour pouvoir
rentabiliser le séjour du patient est
donc évidemment la philosophie de notre
travail a disparu et bien sûr il faut
ajouter à cela une reconnaissance
insuffisante
des paramédicaux avec des salaires
plutôt bas sans
valorisation de leur travail et surtout
sans perspective de progression dans
leur carrière donc pour tous ces points
là évidemment il faut
revoir les choses très rapidement après
l'élection présidentielle
en tout cas nous attendons les projets
de chaque candidat dans ce sens très
rapidement
françois dernière question pour revenir
sur le port du masque demain et il va y
avoir une nouvelle grosse manifestation
est très certainement il aura pas de
masque sur certains visages alors que là
la densité elle sera très forte
oui mais comme je vous l'aï dit à moins
que un arrêté soit prêt et publié de
marc les manifestants nous courons
aucune contravention c'est leur choix de
le porter ou de ne pas le porter et sur
ce point je n'ai encore aucune
contravention mais ils peuvent
risquer d'attraper quand même le locaux
vides 19 avec la proximité d'autres
d'autres manifestants merci messieurs
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
samuel française rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de droit privé à l'université
de rennes merci bruno m'égare ban chef
du service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris